mark for the past three years you've
come in first and J for the past two
years you've come in second how awkward
is it right now to be sitting is with
the event it's very good spirited we're
all here for the cause to help report
this help support Memorial
sloan-kettering Center great cause I
mean we know the answer research Cancer
Research tape they treat more pediatric
cancer patients that any Hospital in the
world so it's a partner with a
foundation like that has been an honor
to meet Jay has been an honor and really
all the participants say your friends in
the event basically your friend I would
say friends you know unless he doesn't
like me I would just say look I feel
like a hero if I make it through a
various boot camp please explain what
exactly is involved in this decathlon
I mean running jumping and lifting is
what I'll kind of narrow down to so
there's ten events you do back to back
to back so 40-yard dash 400 800
benchpress pull-ups and dips with Jay
dominates year after year so kind of
have a whole wide array of things so
it's not a traditional Olympic decathlon
there's no javelin there's no pole vault
it's just kind of running jumping it's
the hardest event for each of you thank
you I think that's the event that
everybody really everybody hates that
more so than the 800 meter run oh I I
think sorry because you guys are just so
much muscle it's hard to breath no I
well I think at the the 800 is the last
event of the day so I think at that
point everyone's just really glad to see
the finish line in sight and and get
past that but the 500 I think really
saps everybody I have a friend who
competes in the decathlon and maybe this
is a little bit of sour grapes but he
says in order to be a contender you've
got to be a super serious at to super
serious athlete who's just an all-around
freak
I mean County and I think what is
getting out there is that how do you
balance right work life and the need to
train as hard as you have to train to be
competitive in an event like this
commando firm yet the big thing is
thinking about the cause and to help out
morale sloan-kettering to know that
we've been able to raise five million
dollars so far through the decathlon for
this year we're trying to raise
two million dollars so far last year in
one day alone we raised over $200,000 so
the training is motivated by that you so
the training I mean so that's so that's
but that's part of it driven by the
cause is you want to get better working
out like five nine days a week you're
off to Train so it's either before work
or after work I mean that's the thing
it's just always making time I mean
knowing it's for cause so if you can get
in if you have half an hour
a few 45 minutes you can go to the gym
go for a run outside there's really no
drink you can do that to 24 hours in a
day Jay what's what's your weekly
training regimen like well I for your
hazard pertains to this and I think mark
touched on it you know you're you're
really motivated by the fact that you're
asking people the you know to donate and
you really want to feel like you earn
those donations I mean you know I have
every dollar that is donated goes
directly to Memorial sloan-kettering for
you know for and it supports you know a
great team of oncologists and you know
and I think this year in particular its
funding trials for 20 percent of of
children who don't respond to
traditional you know traditional cancer
treatments and so you know when you ask
people to donate on your behalf I think
you really want to feel like you earn it
so for me I mean I I have I work out six
days a week and in preparation for this
event how many hours a week it's about
an hour and a half to two hours a day
same for you yeah about that what's its
insane-looking mass so this this is a
mass yeah that yeah I get that that's
what everybody kind of nicknames it can
you put up oh I I think I think I'm sure
of you if he wants to I think it looks
it looks perfectly good on the table
there but it's a high altitude training
mask so the idea and if you talk you'll
sound kind of like Bane and so it you
know honestly I feel put it on properly
after after finishing a second for a few
years I just thought well I need
something different yeah and you know no
reason no reason not to not to give it a
shot so mark are you kind of shook right
now
yeah training name the scary guy that a
scary I mean yeah I don't want to see
that Mike show up in my nightmares I
mean yeah he's a bit of a germaphobe I
see on Sunday yeah guys keep asking me
stupid questions I think you some money
you did I said I got to take it off so
that's the thing is today we're trying
to raise the most money that Decathlon
has ever raised in one day so our goal
is $200,000 to donates WWE decathlon org
go then you can donate to any competitor
that you like fantastic it's a great
cause Memorial sloan-kettering